we have quietly seen over the course of
a decade plus
some uh consistently significant
performance from matt ryan and you don't
think of matt ryan
as a surefire hall of famer but his
numbers are piling up and he's close to
50 000 passing yards he's close to 300
touchdown passes and i don't want to ask
whether you're one of the hall of fame
voters i'm not asking you to tell me
whether or not you think he's a hall of
famer now
what do you think he needs to do though
to make it more clear and obvious that
he's a guy who gets into canton
i don't think he's a dan marino so i
don't know that he can go into canton
without a super bowl so that would be
the first step is getting that super
bowl and he may need more than one super
bowl um it so
piling up the numbers is great we're in
a different era than than we were in in
probably even the 90s maybe the 2000s
but you know they are going to pile up
those passing yards so you kind of take
that a little bit with the grain of salt
and then factor in everything else so
super bowl to me is the biggest thing he
can do now if he gets two of them i'd
say you know he's probably going to be a
lock to get into the hall of fame
because he will have the championships
he'll have the mvp award he'll have
piled up the yards he will piled up the
years so i don't know he would check off
at that point most of the boxes but you
know you go back to eli manning when i
start thinking of him he has the two two
super bowl championships and i'm still
not completely sold that he's a hall of
famer
well and you made a point uh uh recently
when when we uh did one of these that uh
you think that that eli manning is
actually hurting his candidacy by
hanging around and and authoring some
years that don't compare to some of his
best years that becomes part of his
total body for work and body of work and
actually longevity could work against
him when it when it comes time to figure
out whether or not he gets in
yeah there's no question about that mike
i do think that and
because we're remembering eli manning at
the end of his career which hasn't been
very good it's been a long time since
we've seen good eli manning and he
doesn't have the mvp award he doesn't
have the all-pros he doesn't have all
those other things you look for out of
great quarterbacks yes he has the
numbers but only because he's played a
really long time he's never put up
consistently those big numbers in the
regular season where you go hey he's an
mvp candidate never thought of eli like
that his best play has come in the
postseason in those two postseasons
where the giants won super bowls so yes
i think we're remembering the eli as we
see him now rather than the goodie lie
that we saw in those two post seasons
with matt ryan he's got the 2016 league
mvp award he's got the super bowl
appearance that almost was a super bowl
victory he's piling up the statistics
and uh you know the longevity looks like
something he will also manage to satisfy
i think at the end of the day he's got a
pretty good shot the problem is he's
playing quarterback in an era with so
many great ones
he
he doesn't really stand out and i don't
know if that's a personality thing a
team thing or whatever but he just
doesn't jump off the page the way other
great quarterbacks do
yeah we've seen that in different eras
you look how long it took ken stapler to
get in the super bowl and what he had
done he had checked off most of those
boxes himself and it just took forever
for him to get in the super bowl because
he was overshadowed by all the
quarterbacks who played in his error
particularly in terry bradshaw and roger
stahlbach so
yeah it happens uh and it's probably
going to happen a little bit to matt
ryan where you think okay is he going to
make the all decade team because that's
a really big deal too when you start
looking at the hall of fame probably not
because you played with too many great
quarterbacks in this era
who were better than him but he's been a
really good quarterback for the length
of time he's been in the nfl so far and
as you said he has had no durability
problems he's been durable no injury
concerns
so i think he's going to play a lot
longer and put up a lot more numbers
yeah a lot of chapters left in that book
for
matt ryan and by the time it's all said
and done he's laid the foundation
quietly to uh be one of the all-time
greats and he quietly may end up being
indeed one of the all-time greats by the
time it's all said and done all right we
are done for today shireen great work as
always we will be back on thursday with
another edition of pft live big cat will
be on thursday sims is back on friday
and we will be posting content all day
long at profootballtalk.com everybody
have a great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports